2016 is already coming to a close this
is kind of insane I cannot believe this
year has blown by this fast and it is
time once again to talk about my picks
for my favorite movies of 2016 these are
my personal picks and this year I have
done 15 in the past I've done 10 or even
up to 20 this year there were so many
good films that I just had to include
five extra for this list a lot of people
have referred to 2016 it's not the
greatest year for a film and I guess
that'd be true if all of your hopes and
dreams were riding on movies like
Independence Day resurgence or Jason
Bourne if your livelihood rests on the
success of those movies well then I'm
sorry because this year is probably kind
of sucky for you yes there were a lot of
misfires this year in the big-budget
franchise category we're going to talk
about a few of the really good ones in
that category but there were a lot of
films I think this year that flew under
people's radar and we're going to talk
about a lot of those and just like every
year I do have a few honorable mentions
some great films that I really wanted to
put on this list but didn't quite make
it and those films are hell or
high-water hunt for the wilderbeest reat
Kubo and the two strings fences and 10
Cloverfield Lane and like I say every
single year but I must reiterate once
again grades don't matter here this is
not an automatic ranking based on grade
these are my personal favorite films
that I can see myself watching over and
over again for years to come
so let's get going with number 15
[Music]
the witch is one of the most underrated
films of 2016 I think it's an excellent
horror film very slow burn a lot of
really good tension very well directed
and acted if you've never seen this
movie and you enjoy horror films
especially more unconventional horror
check it out
[Music]
Swiss Army Man for me is one of the most
original films of the year a lot of
critics did not get this film a lot of
people said I don't know he farts a lot
he's dead that's okay that's weird
I love twists army man I found it
incredibly subversive completely
different and wholly unique a rival
confirms beyond the shadow of a doubt
that Denis Villeneuve is one of the best
directors working today if enemy
prisoners and Sicario and insan d-didn't
this is that film that I think a lot of
people are going to remember as the film
where they first started to really
notice that name and perhaps it's the
film that can make his name a household
name even though a lot of people can't
really pronounce it this film was a
fantastic science fiction movie a very
different alien invasion film and this
is something we're going to talk about a
lot on this list movies that are of a
certain genre but did it in a unique way
[Music]
Patterson a movie so mundane and
seemingly inconsequential that it felt
very fresh and original I loved Adam
driver in this movie I loved watching a
movie that was essentially a tribute to
everyday people and it was so funny
and so real seek this one out if you
missed it
[Music]
Zootopia for me is my favorite American
animated film that came out in 2016 this
was a great animation that was extremely
entertaining and very fun to watch but
also had really good themes and a great
message that was underneath the surface
and kids can watch it and appreciate it
as an entertaining movie but adults who
are looking for a little bit more in
their films can really also appreciate
the fact that this movie had something
to say and I think it's a really good
film for kids to see Manchester by the
sea was one of the most realistic films
I saw in 2016 the drama was so real and
palpable it was such a poignant film and
very crushing emotionally Casey Affleck
and Michelle Williams were amazing in
the film all of the acting felt as if I
was watching real people it didn't
necessarily feel like I was watching
characters that were written on a page
and then transferred to screen it just
felt like I was watching real things
happen before my eyes and I felt like
after it ended I could have watched a
lot more the boy and a beast was
directed by Mamoru Hosoda and was an
anime film that came over to America I
found this film so touching incredibly
well animated and I think it's really
gone under a lot of people's radars for
me it's one of the most underrated films
of 2016 it was kind of like Karate Kid
except told in a far more fantastical
way if you missed the boy in the Beast
and especially if you like anime but
even if you don't I highly recommend
checking this film out it always bugs me
how films like this are just kind of
thrown into theaters and then no one
ever talks about it again the bowing the
beasts I think is one of the most
touching animated films that I've seen
and one of the most underrated films of
[Music]
they pulled it off Captain America Civil
War was a total blast this is a film
that I was really anticipating I would
have liked to have seen it higher on my
list but in the long run it's on my list
because it actually was that good
does Spider Man have to be in this movie
yeah he's awesome
he's spider-man he's one of my favorite
superheroes of all time and even though
you can kind of look at that and say
maybe they shoot him in I think they
found a really great middle ground of
introducing that character it was a
great conflict between our heroes it
wasn't just about battles and action and
I think it all came to a head
beautifully it was exciting this is
everything a blockbuster movie should be
[Music]
hacksaw Ridge was Mel Gibson's
triumphant return to directing I loved
Apocalypto I loved Braveheart I even
enjoyed the man without a face and a
passion of the christ' I think is a good
movie this is a fantastic war film it's
so gritty it's so realistic in its
depiction of horrific violence and it
made war truly feel like hell Andrew
Garfield was incredible in the film
Vince Vaughn was really good this film
got good performances out of Luke Bracy
and Sam Worthington and for that reason
alone it deserves to be on this list
[Music]
moonlight this is a film that I can't
see myself rewatching a lot because it
is very long and it's very depressing
and it's very intense in its depiction
of a boy growing up in a harsh urban
environment but despite the fact that I
can't see myself popping this blu-ray in
every once in a while I couldn't find a
single flaw with this movie this film is
directed so masterfully and it told its
story with such beautiful heartfelt
emotion I think if you missed this film
in theaters definitely seek out that
blu-ray when it comes out
[Music]
Deadpool this was for me one of the
biggest surprises of 2016 I was excited
about this movie I was careful though I
was like ah last time Ryan Reynolds
portrayed Deadpool in a film that really
went south and all of my worries just
went out the door within the opening
credits alone this is one of the best
adaptations of a comic-book hero to the
big screen regards to capturing the feel
the tone in the essence of that
character
I love Deadpool again everything a
blockbuster movie should be your name is
the anime film that I got to see in LA
when it was doing its Oscar qualifying
run and I was so glad that I did because
this film truly touched me it's my
favorite animated film of 2016 it's a
great great story that tells a romance
in a very unique body-swapping way that
I've never really seen in animation and
not too much in live-action either there
are movies that swap gender roles and
people go in and out of other people's
bodies but it was never quite told in
this way and it also mastered something
that's very hard to do especially in
animation when you start at a film and
it's very light-hearted there's that
transition where it gets too serious and
sometimes in film that's where you mess
up bridging that gap between fun and
light-hearted to intense and emotional
and this film did it perfectly I highly
recommend checking out your name I know
a lot of you never saw it and some of
you probably haven't just because it
hasn't come to your area yet when it
does please go see this movie I'm sure
you're going to enjoy it silence is
Martin Scorsese's latest masterpiece
this film was psychologically brutal
there are sequences in this movie that
were so tough to watch it penetrates the
human soul of these characters so well
it's such an investing story even though
it's very long and there are a lot of
sequences that can go on and on there's
always a reason for a shot in this film
and Scorsese told it so brilliantly as
usual when silence starts to expand into
more theaters definitely see this one
guys martin scorsese is continuing to be
master at what he does la-la-land
I had to see this one again I saw it a
second time just to make sure where it
was on my list this film got even better
the second time I have only one flaw
with lala land I think that's a little
too long I think maybe about 15 minutes
could be trimmed off of that runtime
other than that this is one of the best
if not in my opinion the best musical
ever made Gosling and Emma Stone are
brilliant in this film there are so many
amazing musical numbers and dance
sequences and it is as close to
perfectly directed as a film like this
gets it feels like you're watching a
movie that was made in the 1950s today
in the theatre lala land is amazing if
you missed it in theaters definitely
check this one out because it is
starting to expand more it is one of the
best films of the year and for a musical
to be this high on my list you know it's
pretty damn good
well guys it has come down to this what
is my personal pick from my favorite
movie of 2016 the blu-ray that I've
watched the most the movie that I went
to the theater the most times to see
well that film is a sharp I may have
noticed that I am dressed in Ryan
Gosling's outfit from that movie the
nice guys is my favorite movie of 2016
this is a film that people just don't
make anymore when's the last time you
saw a great detective noir style mystery
these films aren't on the market anymore
and it's no surprise this film tanked
heavily at the box office
nobody saw it no one's talking about it
anymore
everyone that I have talked to about
this film that did actually see it liked
it or loved it I've not talked to a
single person that didn't like the nice
guys I think it is such an original film
Shane black wrote and directed the
out of this movie his script is so
incredible I just re-watched it last
night on blu-ray to make sure this is my
favorite movie of the year and despite
having seen it multiple times already I
laughed my ass off the entire time
Gosling gives I think one of the best
comedic performances that I have seen in
the past five to ten years Russell Crowe
is such a great companion piece for him
they work together so well
chemistry is amazing if you watch these
two in interviews for the nice guys
they are great this is a movie that has
a fight scene with Keith David in it if
you're a fan of the movie they live well
then you know that a fight scene with
Keith David is a pretty awesome thing to
see let's talk about an gory rice in
this movie my god one of the most
underrated performances of 2016
her accent in this movie is perfect she
is so great in this movie and so funny
it's no surprise that she's in the new
spider-man film if you watch the blu-ray
special features of this movie and go to
the always bet on black special feature
you will hear Shane black talking about
the fact that he wanted to make a sequel
to this that he actually says I could
make movies like this with these two
characters for the rest of my life and
he goes I'm not saying sequel but sequel
and of course no one saw this movie
because you know there's no superheroes
in it the nice guys is the type of movie
that people who love film should support
please go out and buy this movie on
blu-ray or rent it on Amazon don't
download it don't torrent it actually
support this film the novelization is
even good I've read it it's good the
soundtrack is amazing my wife bought it
from me on vinyl my friend and I dressed
up like the nice guys for Halloween this
year which was so great and Russell
Crowe even noticed and retweeted that
was one of the coolest and most fun
nights in my entire life the nice guys
is my favorite movie of the year I think
it's incredibly funny I think the action
set-pieces are great I think it has two
characters I would love to see more from
and the most underrated screenplay of
the year for me the nice guys is 2016's
edge of tomorrow except edge of tomorrow
is actually getting a sequel supposedly
and made a lot more money guys thank you
so much for watching my videos in 2016 I
had a great time talking movies with you
guys what are some of your favorite
picks of this year what are some movies
you found underrated this year I'd love
to know and stay tuned because my worst
of the Year video is coming very soon
you guys are the best thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my nice
[Applause]
[Music]
you